[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
nouvelle édition d' espace autochtone en
direct merci d'être avec nous encore une
fois cette semaine
cette semaine nous allons nous
intéresser à un ouvrage fondamental
voilà mythes et réalités sur les peuples
autochtones
nous allons en parler avec celui qui a
écrit cet ouvrage pierre lepage qui est
en studio aujourd'hui avec nos monsieur
de pages bonjour bonjour et bien sûr
avec isabelle picard que nous retrouvons
encore une fois cette semaine bonjour
isabelle nous allons également nous
rendre du côté de saguenay rejoindre
marc au bacon on va d'ailleurs tout de
suite vérifier s'il est avec nous
monsieur bacon vous êtes là aujourd'hui
oui voilà bienvenue coucou et merci
d'être là aussi vous êtes un consultant
en éducation des premières nations
entre autres et puis vous êtes et
d'ailleurs vous avez changé de poste ya
pas très longtemps vous êtes l'ex
directeur du centre des premières
nations ni can eat de nickel qui veut
dire qu'on va de l'avant avec que
l'université du québec à chicoutimi mais
vous avez quitté ce poste dont il ya pas
très longtemps pour vous diriger comme
consultant en fait vu pour être plus
précis j'ai comme officiellement donc
aujourd'hui je jette de consultant pour
le compte présentement pour le conseil
en éducation des premières nations le
cepn ainsi que ceux qui en a qui est au
québec
exactement voilà alors l'idée
aujourd'hui de cette émission c'est de
parler des mythes autour des autochtones
des préjugés autour des autochtones et
on va essayer de faire tomber plusieurs
barrières
mais avant ça je vous ai envoyé deux
questions auxquelles j'aimerais que vous
répondiez tous les trois alors première
question parce qu'évidemment on va
toucher à ce qui se passe en ce moment
dans ce conflit qui oppose la nation
watsu étonne avec cosson gaz ligne mais
aussi les diverses manille
les stations à travers le pays les les
blocages de voies ferrées etc
alors première question c'est est que
pensez-vous de la couverture médiatique
depuis le début de la crise est là
j'aimerais bien que vous me parliez de
la couverture autant à radio-canada dans
les autres médias mais qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
qui a envie de se lancer je veux bien
mais il peut enfin ce que je trouve
intéressant cette fois ci si on compare
à d'autres crises qu'on a eu dans le
passé c'est qu'on entend au moins des
voix autochtone donc ça on entend ici à
radio canada on en entend tv or 90 ans
bon dans à la radio également on en lit
sur papier donc ça je trouve ça
intéressant cette nouvelle voix qui
s'élèvent qu'on n'aurait pas vu quelques
années à l'époque la crise d'oka il n'y
a pas grand doute lorraine qui se sont
exprimés non non pas parce que j'étais
très jeune mais quand même à mon scenihr
évidemment on interrogeait les gens
ellen gabriel évidemment mais c'était on
n'avait pas dix ans et cette position de
recul de commentateurs ou d'un et
l'objectivité d'analysé donc et
maintenant on l'a donc je trouve ça
intéressant ça permet d'apporter 10 ont
un âge où une vision de l'intérieur donc
ça c'est ce que je pourrais dire
concernant ce que j'ai vu maintenant on
a vu du bon et du moins bon ça c'est
évident on a vu des animateurs des
journalistes qui était malheureusement
méconnaissance de la situation et que sa
teinte et un peu les entrevues
d'un côté ou de l'autre ou du côté de
l'ignorance finalement il
malheureusement ça je trouve ça dommage
on a encore du chemin à faire je pense
que les les journalistes les gens des
médias ont encore du chemin à faire dans
l'apprentissage de des réalités et des
enjeux autochtones
monsieur de pages mais je pense qu'il ya
des efforts qui sont faits
moi j'ai vécu justement les événements
au corps plus âgés la pauvreté des de la
couverture médiatique à cette époque là
c'est absolument incroyable
serge bouchard résumé isère on le savait
lorsque le lasagnes gérait bien son
supprimons rester sur notre appétit sur
les enjeux du conflit alors ça résume
bien un peu la pauvreté de et met donc à
des efforts qui ont été faits mais made
you can à deux je me suis apprécié
vainement de haut quand j'y participe
avec l'assemblée des premières nations à
une journée de formation
le cir pme concernées du questions
étaient ici il y avait donc des efforts
qui ont été faits au niveau de l'
embauche dans les journaux dans les
quotidiens on omet andy journal et
savoir si oui c'est important
maintenant j'aurais préféré qu'on ait
plus de 2,2 et point de vue plus
différents moi j'ai pas entendu constat
roi cherche par exemple j'ai pas il y en
ad'autres également du côté de masse th
peu partout et on ne prend rien tant sur
mios saganash par exemple on est
peut-être cela à joindre mais notez donc
ça serait intéressant de meilleures
voies pour le djia tickell qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
surtout vous habitez à lévis vous êtes
alors ailleurs au québec il ya des ce
qu'on appelle là bas des radios
poubelles avec des commentaires mais je
dois vous dire que je les écoute pas
beaucoup en fait je suis à la retraite
et puis après la halle lorsqu'on a lancé
la 3éme édition j'ai jugé annoncé un peu
j'ai que je prendre un peu de distance
par la provocation j'ai accepté de faire
une émission ou téléjournal de radio
canada pour parler des événements de
restigouche pour parler des événements
de oca notamment sur l'utilisation des
forces policières et les dangers que ça
peut comporter mais j'ai mon propre aux
centenaires sont donc à mes expériences
passées et j'essaye de prendre certaines
instances où sid pas vraiment intervenir
sur les
oui d'accord allons maintenant du côté
de saguenay avec monsieur bah quand
monsieur vacances que vous lisez ce que
vous écoutez ce que vous voyez à la
télévision est ce que vous êtes
satisfait parlez nous de la couverture
médiatique
tout d'abord je te fais d'accord avec
les propos d'isabelle et de pierres moi
ce que je trouve déplorable souvent
c'est que c'est des journalistes c'est
comme il essaie de trouver un moyen
terroriser la population où je les sens
des fois quand même assez agressif cas
que le premier ministe québec s'est
présenté hier je pensais que le journal
ici à un des journalistes qui sait
qu'ils étaient vraiment agressifs dans
ces questions dans ses propos puis je
trouve ça un petit peu déplorer pire à
quelque sorte d'essayer d'aller s'est
trouvé d'autres nouvelles mettons comme
des fonds on dirait qu'on essaie de
provoquer une crise humanitaire par
rapport à qu'est-ce qui se passe
question de céder de soulever soulever
la population contre ce qui se passe à
faire un petit peu occulté aussi
occulter le propos qui est vraiment
l'enjeu et les passions s'apaisent ya
deux semaines c'est parti du fait qu' il
y avait des femmes colombie britannique
et par duff en train de faire une
cérémonie puis la grc rang après la
danse on voit plus les images sans cas
nous on les voit plus mais c'est une des
raisons aussi puis jusqu'à hier aussi un
moment donné il faut qu'ils aient un
certain respect parce que les
journalistes ils savent qu'il faut pas
qu'ils aillent vous ira trop proche des
barricades parce que c'est ça fait deux
semaines qu'on leur dise et lesté de
votre côté l'europe promet un caméraman
je suis aussi
la formation vient voler un kamikaze
s'est approché d'eux des barricades
évidemment c'est être rabroué fait deux
semaines qu'on qu'ils savent que c'est
il faut se respecter
jo qui va des trains qu'ils veulent
manifester c'est pas un moment donné il
faut être un peu logique manière pour la
sollicitation des des chroniqueurs des
analystes autochtone est ce que vous
trouvez qu'elle est suffisante on l'a
abordé un petit peu tout à l'heure mais
isabelle je sais que là vous avez été
pas mal sollicité quand même ces
derniers jours oui puis j'avance dans le
même sens que monsieur lepage ça serait
bien d'avoir d'autres voix parce que
honnêtement on est sûr sollicité j'ai dû
avoir au minimum une quinzaine de
demandes dans la première semaine
cette semaine j'en ai eu peut-être cinq
ou six également donc une vingtaine en
tout c'est des grosses démission j'ai
fait hier soir tout le monde en parle
j'ai fait 2 au mans dans mon salon tout
le monde en porte qui sera diffusé
dimanche dont je le dis tout de suite
vous pourrez voir et entendre isabelle
ou si je savais qu'ils avaient lâché
donc pour parler de ce sujet oui mais
est donc ce matin on a évité encore pour
faire l'émission de patrick masbourian à
la radio un moment donné il faut aussi
dormir manger
oui et c'est rendu qu'on ne m'aime peut
même plus le temps de suivre les cours
le cours des événements tellement on est
sollicité on est quelques heures à
l'être mais ça serait bien aussi
d'ouvrir et c'est ce que je fais je
devrais faire de nouvelles personnes je
pense qu'il ya des gens qui sont là qui
ont tout à fait les capacités pour
expliquer les choses ayant les
connaissances bon pierre hours tremblay
et mélissa mollen depuis violemment donc
il y en a d'autres comme ça et éric
cardinal qui est pas autochtone mais qui
est
un allié qui est quelqu'un qui connaît
très très bien la course d'autochtones
on l'a vu également mais ça serait
intéressant aussi d'entendre de
nouvelles voies en tout cas fait moi si
jamais il ya des autochtones qui nous
écoutent
je verrai intéressait vraiment on
cherche ou même des fois à donner des
voix
oui mais vous l'avez dit c'est vrai que
politiquement on entend très peu les
chefs les grands chefs et les entend
très peu c'est vrai que le site us est
un peu délicate et difficile n'est pas
nécessairement consensus de la région
québec ont entendu konrad sioui la
position de monsieur si oui semble assez
clair lui pense que c'est pas le
meilleur et c'est pas le bon moyen
je prends du poids le courage quand même
de dire de sa pensée aussi mais ceci oui
a fait des commentaires ou si c'est
toute la question des traditionalistes
vers ceux-ci conseil de bande etc ce qui
est commun les hurons wendat avait comme
adopté un peu le régime d'aidé conseil
de bande et d'ul historiquement et tout
ça alors que c'était une situation qui
se veut donc il se présentait je pense
que tintin aussi parce qu'évidemment cc
pas noir ou blanc là chacun aussi à des
opinions et même à l'intérieur de la
nation huronne wendat les propos de
monsieur soumis son compte est bon et
absolument c'est ça il ya une diversité
d'opinions on commence à l'entendre et
tous appuyé ce qui est bon mon ami et il
ya les réseaux sociaux les réseaux
sociaux qui est l'occasion de se
défouler pour certains d'expliquer pour
d'autres et là c'est pas évident sur les
réseaux sociaux on entend vraiment de
tout et c'est pour ça que cet ouvrage
devrait se retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les écoles entre les mains
des journalistes parce que c'est un
ouvrage qui permet de savoir qui sont
les autochtones historiquement
politiquement socialement économiquement
pierre le page vous en êtes l'auteur
vous l'avez la fête la première édition
remonte à 2002 donc on était quoi douze
ans après la crise d'oka
à ce moment là comme envoyer ton les
autochtones
moi ce qui m'a décidé à lancer un
programme de rapprochement dans les
écoles avec l'institut tshakapesh faire
une tournée des écoles et c'est dans ce
cadre logique et ce livre c'est un
extrait deux des meilleurs moments des
bleus peau de radio canada
une petite émission qui s'appelait super
morax est à la ramasse et de tous les
préjugés de tous les clichés qui ont
suivi après la crise d'oka et j'ai eu
l'occasion de présenter sa des jeunes
secondaire et je leur demandais ça
correspond tu as à ce que vous pensez
des autochtones
voilà des gens qui détruisent les
maisons qui est qui crachent sur la
facture d'électricité qui lé chèque de
bs leur tombe du ciel et cetera
alors est effectivement oui 99.9 % des
jeunes étaient convaincus que les gens
ne paient pas leur conductrice ticket va
des maisons gratuite qui avait plus de
droits que les québécois qui
respectaient les lois quand alors c'est
vraiment l'ex musique je me suis dit il
faut qu'on fasse quelque chose
et à cette époque là j'ai été beaucoup à
l écoute des des émissions découverte on
a entendu des vertes et des pas mûres à
peu près les mêmes propos qu'on entend
sur les réseaux sociaux faux pas
surprendre alors moi je dis exactement
mais quand même c'était important d'être
à l'écouté de savoir un peu de quelle
façon comment les gens il ya un espèce
de discours populaire qui s'est
installée
c'est pas des opprimés cd privilégiés du
système des exploiteurs système qui ne
paient ni taxes les impôts déjà qui font
rire par le fédéral argile crise
j'ai même demandé à des collègues de
travail dites moi ce que vous entendez
je vais l'écrire il a gémi de langlade
parce qu'à cette époque là la beauté des
cultures autochtones ça ne passait pas
alors où après les événements de haut
qu'on a passé des crises en crises
l'ordre public n'était pas rétablie en
tout cas alors on mange et de lisier sur
les ondes de la radio et donc il fallait
absolument incapable c'est comme ça que
j'ai bâti mais des réalités c'est à dire
chacun des chapitres reprend des
croyances populaires
oui ils ont été conquis ils devraient
devrait s'intégrer ils étaient des
sauvageons n'est vrai tout apporté alors
et j'en ajouter quelques injustement bon
il coûte cher aux contribuables
là comme sûre royalty quick tout jamais
pourquoi et c'est pour les autochtones
que tu as si la situation déplorable
dans lequel il se trouve qu'ils
continuent alors c'est un peu comme ça
que je les bâtis et je pense que le
succès la publication et celui là il va
rejoindre quand même ce qu'on entend les
préoccupations des gens et l'objectif de
donner aux gens des points de repère
pour sortir de ce discours là tout le
monde n'est pas bien dans le même mépris
public et les gens ne demandent et pour
mieux que d'en sortir et moi c'est un
peu la réaction que j'ai de suite
lorsque j'ai sorti seul oui le temps des
gens alors 2002 donc ensuite il ya une
réédition en 2009 enfin des ajustements
des ajouts et donc cent mille copies à
ce moment là qu'ils ont été publiés vous
venez d'en rajouter 15 milles avec une
édition révisée corrigé améliorer les
visées du bic a doublé de volume c'est
peut-être un côté négatif à ce qui est
de conjuguer risation de qui a doublé de
volume qui est un petit peu trop épais
mais je pense que quelqu'un ne faisait
que dans les premières éditions jeu y
comprenez pourquoi les autochtones était
dans le pétrin mais il fallait aller
plus loin nous s'il faut les voir mais
commencer quoi l'avenir etc
et c'est un peu j'ai fait beaucoup
d'entrevues il ya vraiment un
bouillonnement je compare d'ailleurs
rien chapiteau où je parle de 100 sur un
avenir rempli d'espoir où il ya plein de
choses positives
il se retourne à mon avis vivent une
révolution tranquille un peu comme les
québécois ont le vécu et j'ai eu
l'occasion de donner à chicoutimi aducac
justement une conférence là dessus
est ce que les autochtones sont un train
de vivre leur propre révolution
tranquille ya un bouillonnement ya une
effervescence janken fierté identitaire
le passage 15 une volonté de
reconnaissance au plan national
international mouvement des femmes
l'importance du mouvement des femmes
le baby boom et ses terrains et il ya
toute une mobilisation des institutions
d'enseignement
il ya alors il ya des choses très
intéressantes qui se développent et des
partenariats
on comprend maintenant que des
communautés autochtones qui développe
chez des communautés blanches qui se
développe alors tout ça je pense est
important de donner aussi de l'espoir
sur l'avenir ou est ce qu'on s'en vont
avec ça alors avant de savoir comment
vous vous en servez vous monsieur bacon
à saguenay
on va vous avez parlé monsieur de pages
2 à peu près 99 % des enfants qui
étaient à l'époque où à l'époque ces
salles on a des nouveaux chiffres 1
isabelle le en parle de ses passes
nécessairement sur les enfants mais les
préjugés par les autochtones notamment
sont tombés un peu mais un peu quand
même il ya quand même en 2016 l'institut
à environics qui avait fait une grande
recherche une grande étude sur en fait
le tour de préjugés à l'égard des
peuples autochtones et au canada ont dit
que 65 % des canadiens quand même
entretiendrait des préjugés négatifs à
l'égard des peuples aux 65 et 100 sinon
même beaucouzé quand même beaucoup et
c'est dans les prairies qu'on trouvera
lé les taux les plus élevés
possiblement du fait que notamment
saskatchewan les autochtones
représentent 15% de la population donc
je sais beaucoup plus élevé qu'au québec
on est 2 % mais oui ou encore au
manitoba avec winnipeg il ya évidemment
une population jeune en milieu urbain
très très importante et des enjeux
sociaux aussi très important d seront
donc rien à faire alors tout à l'heure
vous avez exposé certains des préjugés
isabelle on va y aller un peu plus en
profondeur avec vous en avez recueilli 5
qui sont les cinq les plus entendus mais
autre que ce que j'ai pu entendre dans
ma vie j'ai fait le top 5 donc une
compilation est le premier donc le
numéro 5 ça serait le fameux on a gagné
la guerre donc dans le sens de ces
correct qu'on vous ait mis en réserve
piquionne loi sur les indiens parce
qu'on a gagné la guerre quels cas
concrets les guerres qui a gagné lequel
guerre c'est là ma réponse il faut se
rappeler
le la colonisation s'est fait dans une
doctrine d'une qu'on appelle une
doctrine de la découverte
quand on parle du terra nullius on en a
déjà parlé assez souvent à l'émission
qui fait en sorte que c'est une terre
sans mettre donc pour les colonisateurs
les français les anglais c'était une
terre qui était 100 m on considérait que
les autochtones qui étaient ici quand
même par millions étaient disons
inférieur et que donc on avait le
pouvoir de prendre possession
on les trie sait les ravages mais voilà
ça donne une idée de comment on les
voilà donc il y avait eu un système de
supériorité de caste
oui vraiment de hiérarchie dans l'esprit
dans la philosophie des colonisateurs
le numéro 4 se serait tu toi c'est pas
pareil du théâtre ados adapté donc c'est
toi la wii et vous les gens me glisse
tout instant et ils le disent à
plusieurs personnes plusieurs
autochtones je suis certaine que
monsieur ben encore un déjà entendu ça
regardez monsieur gbagbo vous avez déjà
entendu ça toi tu été adapté par la
meilleure que j'ai su c'est quelqu'un
que je parlais avec des collègues août
ça lui arrivait quelque chose maintenant
dans l'actualité sur les indiens pilot
tout le monde était choqué sur ce qui se
passe et puis on me disait mais toi tu
époque tout est qu'avec toi t'es pas
content mais est ce que c'est un
commentaire qu'on donnait plus aux gens
aux autochtones qui ne vivait pas en
réserve en communauté non pas
nécessairement parce que j'ai vécu en
réserve pendant 35 ans de ma vie c'est
un commentaire que j'ai entendu tout le
temps je travaillais donc on pouvait
l'entendre à l'université des collègues
étudiants dans les milieux de travail
vous savez des réalités autochtones y en
a il y en a des dizaines et des dizaines
souvent on se dit on se fait une idée du
ou un mythe finalement le mythe
autochtone oui que ça doit ressembler à
ça et ça doit être pauvre et sadoine
arraché et ça doit être sue scolarisés
bon et cetera j'ai eu plusieurs préjugés
et stéréotypes qui hante à travers tout
ça et c'est un peu ce qu'on dit qu'on
dit oui mais toi c'est pas pareil
territoire
je trouve ça un peu drôle adapté à quoi
mon propre territoire
donc la question elle est la numéro
trois c'est vous l'avez souligné tout à
l'heure vous avez des maisons gratuite
et vous ne payez pas d'électricité
j'ai entendu la première fois j'avais 12
ans ce à quoi j'ai répondu tu as raison
mais à 21h le soir innu couple et
l'excellent alors je me suis tourné ça
un peu à la blague parce que j'avais pas
le choix j'étais en secondaire 1 pi
là-bas on sait pas trop quoi dire donc
souvent c'est l'humour aussi qu'il va
nous permettre de nous en sortir
le numéro 2 c'est vous avez votre chèque
le fameux chaque âge on en entend
souvent parler bien sûr
alors de quel chèque on parle moi j'ai
jamais vu ça chez kci y en a un qui
m'attend je vais être milliards et josé
parce que je n'ai jamais collectés on
parle probablement j'imagine dette
sociale qu'on parle de ça mais on a la
même comme dit lui même soit de
financement social s'il en a besoin
besoin oui c'est la même chose sinon je
me suis imaginé qu'on pouvait peut-être
parler des fameux chèque liée aux
traités numérotés et là il faut savoir
qu annuellement les gens qui sont sous
lé traité numérotées c'est pas au québec
il n'y en a pas dû en partir de
l'ontario dont vont recevoir un chèque
annuel qui entrent vraiment on va passer
pour le chèque est le numéro 1 belge
certain que tout le monde le sait c'est
vous ne payez pas de taxes et d'impôts
ça on l'entend tout le temps et je le
vois tellement sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est ainsi
ça fait partie de ce qu'on lit les gens
disent vous aurez quelque chose à dire
quand vous perdez vous paierez syntaxe
et vous impôts comme tout le monde oui
alors que ce n'est pas vrai évidemment
il faut faire quand même la distinction
je vais la faire une fois de plus les
les indiens donc les premières nations
ne paient pas d'impôts quand ils
travaillent à l'extérieur de la
communauté mais dès qu'ils travaillent à
l'extérieur d'une communauté ils vont
payer des impôts pour ce qui est des
taxes qu'ils achètent un bien à
l'intérieur de la communauté ou qu'ils
font livrer un bien à l'intérieur de la
communauté
là ils ne paieront pas de taxe mais
honnêtement des entreprises dans les
communautés y en a pas beaucoup à part
peut-être à luanda qu'il y en a pas
beaucoup
oui donc
l'entrepreneuriat est difficile à
essayer de santé exactement
on pourrait emprunt continue il ya des
choses justifier ça mais bon pour
l'instant et j'aimerais que vous
précisiez pour les maisons parce qu'on
dit ah oui vous de vos maisons sont
gratuites
ouais ben les maisons aux fesses et qu'
il faut savoir qu'on nous a quand même
délogé de grands territoires pour
pourquoi pour faire des parcs
provinciaux des parcs fauniques
notamment pour les barrages banques
trouvent électrique pour l'exploitation
du territoire et cetera et quand on nous
on nous déplacer ben oui le ministère
des affaires indiennes barre 17 des
petites maisons pour les autochtones
mais pour les gens qui se sont déplacés
dans ses réserves leur notamment dans le
nord dans les régions plus éloignées les
maisons de réserve c'est pas le pérou
c'est le cas de le dire c'est la base
c'est la base c'est tout petit souvent
c'est surpeuplée parce qu'il y en a pas
beaucoup de ces maisons là donc on peut
se retrouver à 9,10 dans une maison où
il ya deux chambres des fois c'est mal
isolés dont kill you to south est de
toute façon et j'ai mangé jamais une
maison gratuite d'une communauté dans
une réserve
on ne peut pas être propriétaire mais ce
qu'on le veuille ou non on ne peut pas
maintenant ça commence à changer
aujourd'hui et peut commencer
je suis pas faire du crédit leezam de
communautés pikogan jusqu'à récemment
tout le monde était locataire donc
demander un loyer ça veut dire en
réaction de ton revenu oui et mais
actuellement ils sont entrés je sais que
des gens travaillent pour ce je sais pas
où ça en est rendu exactement si
différent dans d'autres communautés
aussi où on a essayé mais il reste que
tu tu t'étais bi poin oui tu veux tu
peux pas la rendre à qui tu veux dans la
libre disposition de ses biens j'estime
à une annonce remax royal lepage
on ne passait dans une communauté
menteur et il est évidemment les maisons
n'ont pas de valeur marchande aussi
alors moi je donne souvent l'exemple de
moi on a excusé moi diva travail est
mort hier on a déménagé justement de
longueuil à lévis on a vendu notre
maison alors moins ma conjointe onu 20
titres de propriété non seulement sur la
maison sur le terrain je peux le vendre
à qui je veux un égyptien est cher à la
maison de valeur marchande quand j'ai
acheté dans les années 80 ça valait s
j'ai acheté à 50000 de l'armée thaïe pas
de maison à longueur de 250 mais je vous
dis pour conduire le vendus alors oui
les gens ont pas ça dans les communautés
autochtones pour moi c'est un patrimoine
pour ma famille mes enfants et tout ça
alors il n'y a pas ça dans les
communautés autochtones
maintenant il ya quand même de l'aide à
l'accès les propriétés maintenant est
souvent c'était de l'oeil conditionnelle
ou fait que les gens n'est pas d'arrêt
âge avec le conseil de bande par exemple
qui avaient payé leur loyer
c'est pas vrai que les gens payent pas
si les gens ne paient pas d autres
lysine ou de la communauté ou lisse s'en
plaindrait pourquoi moi je paierai si
les autres pays pour cesser c'est
totalement faux
vous monsieur vacon à quels préjugés
avez vous eu à faire face outre outre
les cinq grands préjugés que vient de
sortir isabelle quelques l autre vous
entendez vous même dans votre région
mais je voudrais quand on en attend
plusieurs mais c'est pour venir un petit
peu à ce que pierre martiaux n'est pas
tout je pense que j'aimerais ça aussi
amené à mener cette information lors
c'est que souvent nos étudiants tous
tant qu'acheteur d'université même au
niveau des collèges c'est des étudiants
qui viennent étudier ici puis déjà des
foyers ont beaucoup de difficultés à
trouver un loyer ça ce procès si ça se
passe à juliette ça se passe partout au
québec parce qu'ils y ont des enfants et
ce que je veux amener comme information
c'est que souvent le monde le savent pas
c'est qu'un quart des étudiants aux
étudiants viennent étudier
si c'est pour améliorer leur sort puis
éventuellement retourner à la communauté
donc ils vont ils vendent pas leurs
maisons pour venir étudier ces il faut
qu'ils conservent leur maison dont ils
payent un loyer ils viennent étudier ici
il paye un autre voyez ici se fait qu'un
allemand donné il ya comme cette
sensibilité là aussi qu'il faut qu'il
faut comprendre c'est pas du luxe pour
les autochtones les réutiliser c'est en
milieu urbain oui ce sont cette année
démarre piano plein d'autos s'il a des
difficultés rencontrées et les garderies
les places dans les garderies donc des
préjugés
on a les étudiants en vivent beaucoup
puis ça se ressent aussi c'est dans leur
cheminement scolaire qui pour ça
d'autant plus que l'on parle de mythes
et réalités parce que mettez réalité
pour nous ça fait pas ça faisait partie
nous c'est de notre quotidien d'essayer
de sensibiliser et la communauté
universitaire dans un premier temps on
en a distribué des mythes et réalités je
pense que c'était aux étudiants aux
profs à la communauté on faisait venir
souvent pierre aussi pour venir offrir
des conférences mais au delà de la
communauté universitaire il ya aussi la
communauté mais j'adore la ville de
saguenay des autres citoyens donc il
faut il faut aussi là-dessus travailler
encore plus fort pour essayer encore
plus d'aller sensibiliser parce que les
étudiants qui viennent étudier même
s'ils ont une sécurisation culturelle à
l'université ça veut pas dire qu'ils
l'ont ces cas qui marchent dans la rue
qui vont s'entre dachau pc lock sont
plus généreux en train de vivre des
situations désagréables déplorable
jugement de tous les sens pas tout
énumérer celui des préjugés mais chez
carbine beaucoup mais cet ouvrage n'a en
fait à la base monsieur de pages vous
l'aviez écrit plus pour des étudiants du
niveau secondaire demander un visa de
secondaire les anciens secondaire pour
qu'il puisse répondre aux questions des
élèves parce que on allait dans les
écoles on avait conclu une entente avec
la nation innu oui on est une équipe de
dizaines de personnes qui prenaient la
route chaque mois pour venez dans une
école secondaire
moi j'ai visité 85 écoles secondaires à
travers tout le québec et on offrait aux
enseignants du secondaire un atelier
préparatoire
mettez réalité sur les peuples
autochtones joueurs demandait deux
heures d'un cadre d'une journée
pédagogique donc parce que ce que nous
nous animateur il nous faisait avec les
élèves
on monte un chapiteau dans la cour de
l'école satan ça sentait le sapin frais
on avait des jeux des spectacles du
campement nuit souper communautaire des
et on mettait le paquet pour qu'ils se
sentent bien avec des gens libres
hibernation
sauf que le sommeil y revenez y aller
chez eux soit ils armés y avait des
questions à mes salles acquis des
autochtones y aussi bien aux alors donc
c'est important que de doughty aussi des
enseignants et au début geoffrey des
ateliers 4,5 enseignant qui venait mais
après ce comme on avait des attentes
sont obligatoires on ne voit pas dans
votre école si tout le personnel l'école
ne suis pas un atelier préparatoire
m'étais réalité alors j'ai rencontré de
cette façon à peu près de 1500 ans
certes secondaire et qui vit kiki et
réalisait ben quand relais la conquête
puis la crise d'oka qu'est ce qui s'est
passé je redemande et trouvez moi et
autochtone dans les programmes jusqu'à
l'ailé forme de 2006 il suffit vrai et
on espère une la carte on sait pas alors
quand on cirier mans dérape évidemment
il est arrivé des événements malheureux
il y en a pas de poindre pas moi ça
serait quand des droits différents
pourquoi c'est pour régler quoi que pas
de traiter ici alors on qu ils vont s'y
arrêter nous sortir des documents
poussiéreux
puis alors évidemment on dérape ils ont
le vu justement lors de ces événements
là et le mythe de l'indien privilégie
moi je l'entendais en régions soit parce
que il y avait beaucoup de jalousie mais
là vraiment ça s'est répandu à l'échelle
du québec l'a maintenant 2 après les
événements de haut quand chaque
québécois avait quelque chose à dire sur
des autochtones mais qu'est ce qu'il
avait à dire
on a ramassé tous ces clichés au lieu
d'avoir y en avait possible point de
repère et alors alors voilà un peu je
sais % moi je l'avais fait d'abord pour
le secondaire mais rapidement montrent
que si je pense qu'il était jugée grand
public déjà la bri y est facile à
trouver
c'est à dire que je suis très content je
remercie beaucoup la commission des
droits de la personne où j'étais moi
j'ai plus ma retraite de la commission
en 2001 à 2009 et la commission a
accepté que je travaille à la 3ème
édition et cette fois ci c'est une coup
ici avec les chèques à pêche et une
version imprimée il est possible de
l'avoir gratuitement c'est gratuit les
5000 copies ont été gratuite on trouver
le financement
et avec l'entente avec les surboums
faciliter le financement
donc on peut avoir une version imprimée
on le demande à l'institut tshakapesh et
évidemment il est en version facebook
françois vinet not ready maistre que
nous remercions tout de suite puisqu'il
va pouvoir donc la rendre disponible au
plus grand nombre et il est disponible
en anglais aussi une fiction on a de
fait moins de copies mais il est
disponible sur le web
absolument c'est important parce qu'au
début du ministère d'éducation financer
la première édition le ministère était
conscient des lacunes avant la réforme
de 2006 il avait tenté de faire des
documents pour pallier justement
d'espèces de ville de connaissances et
mais le ministère était prêt à financer
une espèce de manuels et quand ils ont
vu l'ailé gauche de documents que
j'avais fait les ont testés ou en barque
ils ont payé la version hadley
d'ailleurs puisque sa voix dans les
écoles anglaises
je suis vraiment très content à gg je
suis très content de ça ça a été un peu
ma contribution locale là quand on est
né écoles les spécialistes de la culture
staline où l'équipe ne s'était pas à moi
à parler pour eux mais moi toute la
question des droits et tout ça donc
c'est plus à l'aise avec ça et j'ai
profité un peu de mon expérience lors de
l'es10 événement sur les crimes
seulement lors de la crise d'oka pour
amener aux gens dit justement 6.2 repas
qui nous manque pour comprendre pu
l'arrêter l'avantagent qu'il soit
maintenant sur internet c'est qu'il va
pouvoir être mises à jour avec les
événements qui se déroulent j'imagine
que ce qui se passe en ce moment avec
impatience votre souhait tonnes
devraient en faire partie un jour oui
absolument il devrait y avoir l'enjeu
c'est qu'à la commission il est question
travailler sur la version web les y ait
des discussions avec les studios cas
péchalat
ça fait par suis partie de la suite des
choses ce qui voudrait dire donc on
pourrait ajouter le compléter et oui
monsieur bako est ce que vous voyez la
différence là maintenant vous n'êtes
plus à l'université mais est-ce
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous l'utilisez
encore aujourd'hui lors de vos
consultations ou de vos rencontres mais
tout à fait c'est de ce que nous quand
on était petits on est obligé
d'apprendre par car le petit catéchisme
pour pouvoir dresser notre voie vers le
fun ya là je trouve que mythe et réalité
c'est un outil indispensable cpo nous
étudiants pour la population put mmm
j'irai même plus loin c'est sûr que je
comprends bien que des fois il ya eu des
choix difficiles à faire
qu'est ce qui va mettre dans pour la
course à 2,0 sa troisième édition
que ce serait maintenant j'aurai une
maison d'édition et j'aurai un gros
financements je pense que j'en ai assez
d'éléments pour chaque titre gratuit
chaque chapitre est d'enfer d'enfer
c'est comme une encyclopédie sur une
thématique une haute et mettre ses
culottes et médecine aux thématiques
c'est sûr que c'est il ya beaucoup à
dire encore puis on peut être des
éléments qui ne sortiront pas pas tout
tout mettre sur sur cette édition là
parce que là mais je pense que quand je
vous disais il aurait peut-être matière
à aller plus loin dans certains
chapitres qui était à ce soit comme un
petit peu comme une encyclopédie ben oui
isabelle est ce qu'il manque quelque
chose dans mythes et réalités sur les
peuples autochtones
moi je le trouve quand même assez
complet c'est tout c'est un ouvrage qui
va faire en sorte qu'on va vouloir si on
n'a pas eu la réponse qu'on veut pousser
plus loin on va avoir les bases ça c'est
extrêmement important
j'utilise beaucoup à l'université entre
autres je donne des cours en lien avec
les autochtones des fois les étudiants
qui arrivent ont aucune connaissance et
là on a des étudiants dont qui ont des
bonnes connaissances donc et non pas du
tout et je dois travailler là dedans
donc mettez réalité c'est ce que je
suggère à ceux qui ont moins de
connaissances c'est aussi ce que chose
que ce que je suggère à des gens que je
rencontre et qui veulent avoir lors des
premières rencontres des premières
discussions un cours 101 sur les
autochtones dans une rencontre qui est
social des nouveaux amis ou en famille
on contexte familial souvent je dis ben
écoutez j'ai pas envie de donner un
cours ici parce qu'on est extrêmement
sollicité à ce niveau là et il ya un
excellent ouvrage qui existe et ses
mythes et réalités donc c'est un ouvrage
qui m'apparaît
la recherche elle est très bonne on voit
que ça a été fait en collaboration avec
les premières nations ça se sent
maintenant c'est un ouvrage qui pourra
permettre d'aller plus loin il ya des
perles dans ce joli encore utiliser
cette semaine pour ma chronique dans la
presse notamment sur le sol y train les
voies ferrées donc il ya des perles la
recherche et les bonnes et les je pense
que c'est un ouvrage qui est un
incontournable
est ce que monsieur bah quand vous avez
vu des différences avec les les jeunes
qui l'ont eu entre leurs mains est ce
que dans leur famille des des préjugés
sont finalement tombée est-ce que vous
avez eu l'impression que ça a changé les
choses
tout à fait on a eu divers expérience
surtout avec nous nous étudiants les
étudiants qui sont non autochtone de
l'université donc on aurait transmis cet
ouvrage locke qui l'ont utilisé dans le
cadre de travaux on a vu que les
étudiants par la suite qu'un qu'on
organisait des événements mais il
participait il voulait aussi travailler
avec nous pour réaliser nos activités
donc ça veut y en ait un impact direct
sur un genre de rapprochement
peut-être que j'ajouterais aussi mythe
et réalité c'est aussi bien bon pour les
attaques tonnes aussi parce que les gens
de ma génération
l'histoire oui c'était très court raté
nos cours d'histoire
c'est pour ces d'un contexte autochtone
c'est moi quand j'ai lu la première fois
me mettais réalité voire plusieurs
années
si j'en ai appris des choses que moi
même j'étais même pas au courant leur
steak et ça ça peut être bénéfique aussi
même pour les attaques temps de lire cet
ouvrage
oui c'est ce que vous m'aviez dit un peu
plus tôt monsieur dommage hors micro
absolue maj je mentionne toujours à ce
cariste à des gens qui m'avaient plein
jour ils viennent nous parler ton
histoire parce qu'il dit au pensionnat
la moindre edit j'ai appris la même
chose que toi n'admet marge il dit en
algérie en a pris
j'irai plus loin il a appuyé à se
mobiliser parce qu'il y avait les
manuels qui parlait 10 autochtone sa
force marin sa quinte importées vers la
débauche et tout ça absolument et j'ai
un petit témoignage afin donc moi j'ai
donné autant de conférences en milieu
autochtone déjà envie on pas un péril
d'où ça vient la loi sur les indiens
personnes à enseigner ça ça pas d'où ça
vient
de quel droit ils sont privés mais
comment en sortir alors moi j'ai des
nues autant de conférences à mieux au
canada les québécois faut pas qu'on
pense que les les autres camps savent
tout sur le nez ce temps ils partent de
loin au dessus vous
il y ajoute un travail de 2 2 il ya eu
un travail de mes connaissances à
combler et géo témoignage à sainté le
sol d'une d'une jeune à chicoutimi lors
d'une conférence de la dernière je pense
que j'ai donné à chicoutimi qui dit
monsieur lepage
moi j'ai pas été dans les écoles il nous
fallait l'école provinciale
quand j'ai lu votre livre je me suis mis
à être fiers des tunisiens alors ça m'a
vraiment touché et je sais que je la
plupart des jeunes des premières nations
ont eu à travailler que se livrent leurs
comptes 1
bon je les fais modestement nommé mais
pour peut-être reprendre ce que marco
vacances j'aime c'est pour moi qui va
travailler à développer chacun des
chapelles comme ils disent avec des
jeunes stars il y aura pas de quatrième
édition
il ya une belle relève alentours de nous
je le constate et marcoux et à sa
retraite justement elle arrive à
l'instant je compte sur lui moi je j'ai
des petits-enfants m'occuper monsieur
bah quand le message est passé vous êtes
consultant en éducation des premières
nations
c'est de l'éducation cet ouvrage là vous
savez ce qui vous attend merci beaucoup
monsieur bacon d'avoir été présent à
l'émission aujourd'hui merci d'y avoir
participé
et continuer à présenter mythes et
réalités sur les peuples autochtones
merci merci monsieur de pages de nous
avoir présenté votre ouvrage vraiment
être un très bon travail qui est
toujours aussi nécessaire mais moi ça
donne pas les réponses sur les
événements qui se passent mais au moins
on y les points de repère et puis merci
à isabelle encore une fois isabelle donc
tout le monde en parle dimanche soir à
radio canada alors là aussi c'est de
l'éducation s'est beaucoup d'éducation
dans un contexte qui n'est pas facile
mais on voit l'ouverture des gens et
vraiment je pense que c'est nécessaire
c'est passage voilà merci à tous les
trois merci d'y avoir participé
et à vous d'avoir été encore une fois à
l'ecoute je vous retrouve donc vendredi
prochain merci au revoir
[Musique]